es ist ein instinkt
[Musik]
angeführt
den markt brachte uns zusammen
nach über 40 jahren star wars geht es
jetzt um den neunten und mehr oder
weniger abschließenden teil star wars
episoden ein skywalker und die leute
wollen antworten ist nämlich ganz
logisch dass sie antworten wollen
als diese geschichte angeht und die
vielen geheimnisse und rätsel der art
wie hängt die skywalker familie mit der
politischen welt dieser galaxis vor
langer zeit und an einem fernen ort
überhaupt zusammen was ist das schicksal
der einzelnen leute antworten halt also
weil man geht er in star wars filme zum
schluss verantworten so wie man in die
achterbahn steigt um von punkt a zu
punkt b zu kommen also ja antworten ich
weiß es auch nicht ich hatte keine
antworten aber ich hatte einen ganz
guten film die erste stunde ist ein
bisschen lang und dann wird's gut
[Musik]
ja
jetzt locker da denken natürlich alle
leute okay jetzt kommt irgendwie noch
mal irgendwas raus aus dieser familie
angeht und wären noch aus welchem ei
geschlüpft ist und du bist mein vater
oder meine mutter ist mein bruder oder
irgend sowas in der tat ist das mit dem
reisen bisschen problematisch weil diese
deutsche übersetzung der aufstieg es
klingt so nach dem büro triumph also der
aufstieg von prokurist bei meetings
berger und ich glaube diese epische
bucht die dieser titel im original hat
die kriegen wir in deutschland deswegen
nicht weil die leute die hier titel
machen die werbung machen ihr leben lang
vor ihrem abitur davonlaufen und denken
sie müssen irgendwie einfach und blöd
sein deswegen nennen sie es nicht die
apotheose skywalkers was tatsächlich der
richtige titel gewesen wäre weil sie
halt denken die leute sind albern und
doof und dabei haben sie auch inception
oder wie war der titel allen covern und
gefressen und man kann sich ruhig mal
was trauen und wer das publikum zu blöd
hält ist blöder als jedes publikum
jemals war und das schöne bei der
champions ist bei dem film dass er das
publikum tatsächlich für blöd hält also
ein paar sachen kommen erst fünf minuten
später raus wie sie eigentlich gemeint
waren und so eine lange
aufmerksamkeitsspanne setzte halt voraus
was machst du da 3 mio ich werfe einen
letzten blick
[Musik]
der prunkbau etwas das länger als 40
jahre geht ist ja dass du viele viele
leute hast die sich zuständig fühlen
das zu beurteilen also auf der einen
seite gibt es diese vorstellungen über
fans können über sowas urteilen davon
lebt das ganze internet aber das ist
natürlich ein bisschen so fans sind wir
fans sind wie alle drogenabhängigen wir
wissen was wir wollen aber nicht
unbedingt was gut für uns ist die andere
vorstellen dass es irgendwelche
außenstehenden superfilm kritikerinnen
und kritiker braucht die das beurteilen
ist dann allerdings ein bisschen so wie
wenn man sagt ob die thüringer bratwurst
wirklich gut gegrillt wurde kann nur ein
veganer beurteilen also du bist
irgendwie gezwungen einerseits als
verein zu gehen und andererseits dann
noch mal zu überlegen war es den ganzen
aufwand wert in diesen 40 jahren und auf
eine art war es das weil es tatsächlich
eine zusammenfassung ist von allem was
amerikanisches glattes protziges
brutales spekulatives ausgedachtes kino
kann und das ohne rückgriff auf zwerge
es ist sehr wichtig also ohne zwerge wie
bei tolkien also gerade für uns ältere
säcke hat diese abschluss trilogie
natürlich ein problem gehabt nämlich so
ein bösewicht loch so ein bösewicht
mangel ich meine dieser first order chef
da wie sehr ihm lieder smoke ist
natürlich ein witz ich meine pantoffeln
an also ich pantoffeln ein bösewicht in
pantoffeln und dann feiert ist so eine
weile rom und man denkt irgendwie es
läuft auf diesen kalorien also m3 war
raus und jetzt enthüllt sich dann nein
das böse ist dasselbe böse dass das böse
immer war ich sag's nicht es ist eh klar
aber es kann so dreckig lachen und hat
total ekelhafte augen und kommt immer
wieder
ja jetzt ist es wieder da und wird auf
eine art besiegt die mehr davon handelt
das hat der zweite teil dieser letzten
trilogie ja schon gesagt die mehr davon
handelt was man eigentlich danach will
und was man stattdessen will als davon
dass böse kaputt zu machen also macht
kaputt was euch kaputt macht reicht
offenbar bei star wars nicht mehr missen
hier habe ich darauf gewartet
[Musik]
die david lee die hat ich weiß gar nicht
wie man das nennen soll wenige blicke
gibt so was also die ist dermaßen straff
dass man plötzlich versteht was dieses
wort spannung eigentlich bedeuten soll
ich glaube das wird uns unser nächstes
ziel war gegen er dem driver der in der
geschichte ein bisschen der schlüssel
ist das heißt er dreht sich tatsächlich
um sich selber und dann geht der plot
auf hat im internet relativ viel mut
gegeben weil der so zurückgenommen
gespielt hat in den ersten beiden filmen
der letzten trilogie die das star wars
film universum haben soll
aber diese zurückgenommene spiel ist
dafür da dass er jetzt sozusagen
auseinanderfallen und sich neu
zusammensetzen kann und das ist alles
ziemlich überzeugend und leute die
gesagt haben wieso braucht deine maske
der hat auch schon eine maske nämlich
seine fresse die werden sich wundern wie
viele masken er noch dabei hat
[Musik]
die macht wird mit ihr sein das
gesamtfazit von 40 jahren mehr als 40
jahren star wars ist neun gute filme
nicht stimmt nicht drei super filme drei
erträgliche filme 3d filme also neun
irgendwie ganz okay film mehr weil man
soll ja mit dem durchschnitt bilden ja
diese prequels trilogie ernsthaft also
motto think
[Musik]
[Gelächter]